morning everybody seven o'clock in the
united kingdom very welcome to spend
your breakfast with us here at sky news
wherever you're watching us around the
world this morning as temperatures start
to fall there are warnings of a winter
of discontent for millions of households
right across the country with the energy
price cap going up today to its highest
ever level
meantime the latest on the met police
and its commissioner over the lack of
vetting for sarah everard's murderer
plenty to discuss with the policing
minister kit malthouse in just a few
moments time also this morning the new
law protecting allergy sufferers in this
teenager's name will speak to the
parents of natasha eden laparouse who
died after an allergic reaction to a
shot-bought sandwich with sesame seeds
that's at half past eight this morning
and
see how lovely it is to start your
morning with us swapping their medical
instruments for musical instruments
we'll chat to one of the performers in
the world doctors orchestra ahead of
their concert at london's barbican hall
this weekend that's at 8 45. it's friday
the 1st of october picture punch dark
days ahead millions of households face
higher heating bills as the energy price
cap rises
i'm live in hodge hill in birmingham an
area that already has one of the highest
rates of fuel poverty in the country to
find out how soaring prices will affect
people here
from norway to northumberland we get an
exclusive look at the world's longest
undersea power cables which should
reduce uk carbon emissions
the police under pressure the met faces
questions for failing to investigate
previous allegations against sarah
everard's murderer as he begins serving
his lifetime
freedom to head down under australia is
set to reopen its borders to its
citizens abroad for the first time in 18
months
a growing island the surface of la palma
expands as lava from a volcanic eruption
solidifies as it flows into the ocean
these are live images of the volcano
which continues to spew lava and ash
into the air
and the weather and mixture of sunshine
and blustery showers
[Music]
good morning families across the country
will have to dig deeper to keep their
homes warm this winter the cap on the
energy price increases today meaning
bills will go up for about 15 million
customers the government says the
increase will protect millions of people
from rising global gas prices let's take
a closer look at what those changes will
mean for you it's thought
around 15 million households will be
impacted those on default tariffs will
see their bills rise to
1277 pounds a year an increase of 139
pounds the regulator offgems says this
increase is driven by a rise of more
than 50 percent in energy costs over the
last six months with gas with gas prices
i should say hitting a record high of
course we've seen the impact of that in
the last few weeks with the gas supply
crisis threatening even higher bills
it's estimated that the price hike will
see more than four million people in
fuel poverty in england
the end fuel poverty coalition says
barking and dagenham stoke on trent
newham shropshire herefordshire
kingsland and west norfolk will be worst
affected by the increase the shadow
business secretary ed miliband has
spoken out against the rising cost of
living
to keep the energy price cap in place
because it's a necessary protection for
customers but what we're seeing is a
cost of living crisis a crisis at the
petrol pumps a crisis in our energy
supplies
and prices
and the reason we're seeing this is
because of a government that has failed
to prepare and fail to plan and i'm
afraid it is the british people and
british businesses who are paying the
price of government failure and the
message to government is get a grip and
stop blaming someone else
becky johnston joins us now from another
area identified as being blighted by
fuel poverty and that's hodge hill in
birmingham hello to you becky
just what the people behind you didn't
want to hear this morning
indeed it's already estimated that
around a quarter of people in this area
are experiencing fuel poverty and that's
before the prices went up fuel poverty
of course means that the cost of
adequately heating your home plunges you
as a household below the poverty line
and people waking up to know that energy
bills now going up by 12
for around 15 million people that's
going to be an extra
139 pounds or more each year it's a huge
uh increase on their bills and charities
warning that it of course comes at a
time
when the extra 20 pounds a week of
universal credit that was given to
people during the pandemic is being
removed and also the furlough scheme is
ending so being described by some as a a
triple whammy on households already
struggling of course the weather today a
reminder that winter is very much on its
way and many charities now warning that
actually families simply won't be able
to heat their homes adequately this
winter and of course that will bring
health consequences for people i've been
speaking to somebody who runs a local
food bank in this area he said he's
gearing up for a two-fold increase in
people needing his services uh this
winter he is in part blaming the rise in
energy increases and says he's already
seeing people coming to him and saying
they're facing the choice between
heating and eating okay thank you becky
thanks a lot uh kit moltas representing
the government with us this morning mr
mold house a choice between heating and
eating that can't be right
well obviously the situation we're
facing at the moment on energy is is
challenging but as you think you said in
your report the uh uh although the
increase in the price cap which is
obviously an independently assessed cap
that's put in place or reviewed every
every six months uh means there will be
a rise it does still mean that uh
through the winter because obviously
it'll persist now um all those
households will be protected uh from the
full impact of the rise of gas and
indeed um if the prices rise uh any
further but look we recognize the the
challenge that people are facing that's
why it's very important that we get the
economy back up and running as fast as
possible it seems to be growing strongly
and hopefully we'll
reach karma times quite soon so what's
your advice on people to people who have
to choose between heating and eating
well obviously you will also have seen
yesterday that the government announced
a 500 million pounds fund to assist uh
people who are experienced that kind of
hardship uh the details of how that's
going to be administered will be
publicized soon and once that becomes
available then i hope that those people
who are in that unfortunate position
will avail themselves of that assistance
yeah it's still not going to be enough
though is what we're being told four
million people in fuel poverty do they
feed the kids or switch the radiator off
well obviously the as i say the
government's putting half a billion
pounds out there to assist people who
are in that challenging
situation and obviously the
through universal credits although
obviously the 20 pounds is coming to an
end but uh through universal credit what
we hope is that that will assist many
people to maximize both their support
from the government but also what
they're able to achieve through working
if that's what they do so we'll keep
this under review but as i say at the
moment the cap at the level it's set
does protect people from further rises
in the energy market you need to look
again at this 20 quid don't you for
universal credit being taken away
well that uh the chance has obviously
reviewed that on a regular basis over
the last few uh
months it was a temporary measure
brought in as part of the
covid uh effort to help people through
that particular uh difficulty what we
hope now is that was we see employment
rising very significantly in the country
there's obviously a lot of vacancies as
we know that people uh can try and
fulfill if they have the skills
available
they'll be able to get back onto the
steadier time should we say from a
financial point of view
thankfully the petrol station uh issue
is easing or is it um petrol station
bosses accusing the government this
morning of gaslighting the public um
where is the fuel
so as i understand it okay the the the
fuel supply into the country is not the
problem there's obviously a distribution
issue that's caused by excess demand if
you like as far as we can tell uh
certainly my information this morning is
that the situation is stabilizing across
the the country uh albeit there's
obviously still high demand for
for fuel let's hope that over the next
few days that eases as people
you know as their tanks fill um and that
extra demand starts to abate a little
and we can get back to a more
predictable pattern of supply
what is why is there a why are we saying
i suppose a mr mulhouse a postcode
lottery if you will of fuel you know um
if you're in the city london birmingham
manchester it's incredibly difficult to
get fuel and you have to go past maybe
10 um petrol station four cores before
you manage to get some
yeah well as i say okay i'm not close to
that effort i've been sadly
concentrating on some of the awful
stories that we've seen recently to do
with the the police
but i do know that there's a team at
bays that's monitoring the distribution
of fuel across the country
they're trying to assist the industry to
get back to a more predictable pattern
of supply obviously demand for fuel
across the country is not always
predictable um that comes and goes
normally that is a little more certain
um but in these in these times where
consumer behavior
allied with a perception of a shortage
of fuel
is driving different levels of demand
obviously we're having to move quite
dynamically to address that and i know
they're working very closely with the
industry to try and ensure that we get
supply back onto a stable footing as
quickly as possible
so it's the motorists and the messenger
swap um no that's not what i said okay i
said there's a different pattern i said
there's different patterns of demand at
different times in different places and
that is at the moment not on the same
predictable pattern that we've seen in
the past now efforts need to be buying
more fuel than normal well yeah that is
the case people are um and people are
naturally responding to what they see
and what they hear and what they feel
now i don't blame them for that people
have important journeys that they have
to make people have a you know they're
required to get to work get their kids
to school all those important things
they need to do but as i say what we're
trying to do is to say to people look if
if we can return to a normal pattern of
consumption then we'll return to a
normal pattern of supply and there is no
problem with fuel coming into the
country yeah and the way to count
people's nose is to get a few um drivers
with their army fatigues moving fuel
around the country that'll count
people's nerves why have we not done
that before now
well obviously there is work that's gone
on around the resilience of the fuel
supply and putting people on on standby
but as i say that there's only so many
tankers there's only so many drivers
there is no shortage of supply at the
moment into the country the question is
the distribution and there's lots of
effort going in to make sure that we get
that pattern stabilized people can get
the fuel they need for the important
journeys they need to make um and
hopefully as i say in the next few days
things will stabilize further and return
to normality in short order you talk
about the horrendous murder of sarah
everard how damaged are the police this
week you're the policing minister
oh it's devastating okay i don't think
there's any uh way of shying away from
that i mean i've as you might know spent
a lot of my adult life working with the
police um and
uh for me and for them it's it's a
dreadful blow and that's over and above
the the total devastation for sarah
everard's parents um that they must be
feeling it's unimaginable uh but the
fact that this man was a serving police
officer when he committed the crime is
just horrifying really um and has made
all of us think hard about a how we how
it happened in the first place and be
how we can prevent it in the future
how damaged are the police as a result
of what happened well i i think as you
heard yesterday from senior police
officers uh they recognized that this
has
struck a a devastating blow to the
confidence that people have in in police
officers out in the public realm um but
also in in the met police in particular
um the circumstances that were revealed
yesterday around the the way this awful
monster perpetrated his crime using the
cover of being a police officer uh
raises a question mark in everybody's
minds and
you know from my point of view for that
well it's
obviously a terrible terrible
catastrophe for sarah everard and her
family uh for those thousands and
thousands of police officers out there
who will have to work harder
much harder
to win the public trust in in the realm
and particularly those of individuals it
is a a very very difficult time
um the labour mp um harriet harman
believes that cressida dick
the head of the met should stand down
why do you think she should keep her job
okay the the being the met commissioner
is i think one of the
possibly top three most difficult jobs
in the in the country uh you handle
enormous risk you're dealing with an
organization which is capable of amazing
things but at the same time
things can go badly wrong as they have
done in this circumstance and what i
want in a in a policing leader is when
awful calamities like this happen and i
think as crester said yesterday this is
you know probably the worst moment in
the 192 year history of the metropolitan
police um that when these awful things
happen i want a police leader who's
transparent willing to learn willing to
change and is has a conviction a
commitment not to be defensive about the
failings of the organization and i think
that's what we're seeing in president
dick when there are failings of an
organization it's the chief executive's
responsibility to take responsibility um
it's she is to all intents and purposes
the chief executive it's not the first
time on her watch that there have been
significant failings why should she keep
her job
well as i said okay it is the most
difficult job and in my experience
having worked with presta over many
years in a number of positions she is a
dedicated and talented and committed
police officer who is driving the
metropolitan police to ever greater
standards
of care and improvement and fighting
crime and she is committed to whatever
changes come out of the lessons learned
of this horrible episode um and that's
what i wanted a police leader someone
who's willing to to change frankly not
just in the metropolitan police but
across the whole of uh uk policing and
we are going through a period of change
in policing the fact that we're
recruiting all these extra police
officers and don't forget to get to our
20 000 extra we've got to recruit
a gross recruitment of about 45 000
officers altogether is a shot of of
youth and energy and different thinking
into british policing which i hope will
start to to change the culture for the
better
yeah okay so a serving police officer
arrests somebody
allegedly puts their hands behind their
back in handcuffs puts them in a vehicle
drives them for two hours
rapes them on the back of the seat takes
them out of the vehicle puts them in a
fridge
burns them hides their phone and then
goes about their normal business uh
exchanges text messages with 15 other
metropolitan police officers who are now
also all under investigation
on her watch
yeah look the the the incident itself is
as you laid out case is just devastating
i mean i i can't get away from that and
i know that that all this all the
metropolitan police officers that i know
will be similarly ashamed and devastated
by it uh the question in in our mind is
is what went wrong right my job is
effectively to to help the home
secretary to hold the police to account
about what went wrong how this monster
slipped through the net to become a
police officer um how we can make sure
it doesn't happen again and what we need
to learn i mean though as you said there
are a number of investigations and
inquiries taking place around this case
which i can't comment on but as those
conclude what we learn about how we can
make sure the police is a a better
organization um and has the trust
unquestioning trust of the british
people and i don't think there's any
question that that's been shaken by
these events
more than 750 metropolitan police
employees have faced sexual misconduct
allegations since 2010
only 83 of those 750 have been sacked
750 metropolitan police employees faced
sexual misconduct allegations since 2010
many of them on her watch
look kay obviously it's important that
we have a very very robust uh
investigation internal investigation
function and one that is independent
that could look at any allegation and
there are obviously lots of allegations
made against police officers uh in the
course of their duty we have revamped
the police
investigations structure over the last
couple of years the independent office
of police conduct now looks at
all sorts of complaints that are lodged
with them
by the public but critically also
the met police in particular
have ramped up their internal um
professional standards organization if
you like and in particular they're
vetting so for example earlier this year
they started routine vetting of officers
social media output
to make sure that they were picking up
whatever intelligence they can look
there's going to be lots of lessons that
we need to learn from this horrible
episode and you know my job as i say is
to hold the police to account make sure
they learn those lessons and they
implement the actions that are needed to
make sure we can avoid this kind of
horrible incident in the future
my son's girlfriend is say approached by
what who claims to be an undercover
officer as she's walking home tomorrow
what do i tell her to do
well the first thing to say is officers
rarely deploy singly um
when officers are sworn as a constable
they do actually swear that if there's
an incident they're off duty i am
playing clothes that they have a duty to
intervene to protect life and safeguard
the public
but if anybody has any doubts about a
police officer um then obviously they
are
they should re question the officer
about uh their what they're doing and
why they're doing it if there any doubts
at all they should ask to either speak
to the control room using the officer's
radio or if in doubt call 999 and ask a
question um you know the the the what
sort of society have we come to mr malt
has where we are so doubting somebody
who says they're a police officer that
we think that we have to dial 999 to
check
well okay i completely understand and
that is the the as i say the devastating
consequence of this awful man's actions
is that he's undermined the good work of
of thousands and thousands of police
officers not just the current serving
ones but all those police officers that
have served over the decades previously
and it's worth remembering that of
course that those thousands of police
officers across the country are doing
amazing things every day to keep us safe
but these kind of stories do raise
question marks in people's minds i can
understand particularly given the
circumstances and i think it would be
perfectly reasonable
in similar circumstances for somebody to
question the officer
seek reassurance if that means speaking
get asking them to identify themselves
by speaking to the control room uh or
calling in 999 if they feel in danger
then i'm afraid that's where we've got
to okay mr multis thank you for joining
us on the program busy day ahead for you
thank you thank you
and very hard days ahead for so many
tens of thousands of police officers
around the country who day in day out
run towards danger
to keep us safe and then you get
somebody like wayne cousins do what hid
he did and as a result they find
themselves in a challenging position
what should happen you i bet you want to
let me know you can tweet me directly if
you would like to at cape olivia's a
whole life tariff
for that man met police questions at 7
30. speaking to zoe billingham who's
just stepped down from her job as her
majesty's inspector of constabulary
she's going to be talking about the
pressures facing not just the met but
police services up and down the country
as a result of his actions
five past eight energy uk's deputy chief
executive audrey gallagher will be with
me to discuss the higher energy price
cap which takes effect from today
an orchestra made up entirely of medics
raising money to support homeless
patients we'll speak to one doctor
performing this weekend at london's
barbican that's at 8 45
looking at some of the other stories
making news for you this morning and
technical problems have been reported
with scotland's covid vaccine passport
app on the day it launched from this
morning people need proof they have had
two doses in order to enter nightclubs
and many large events the scottish
government says the volume of people
trying to access the app may be
responsible for the issue
new research suggests it is safe for
people to get coronavirus flu vaccines
as coronavirus and flu vaccines at the
same time clinical trials across england
and wales found that getting both jabs
in a single visit had no negative impact
on the effectiveness of either the
vaccine
or indeed the flu jab and there were no
safety concerns
the brazilian football legend pele has
left a sao paulo hospital after being
admitted nearly a month ago for surgery
on a colon tumor 80 year old will now
undergo a course of chemotherapy
scientists say spain's la palma island
has grown because of volcanic lava
copernicus the european union's earth
observation programme says satellite
imagery shows a new area of more than
800 acres on the western side of the
island scientists say molten lava is
hardening as it comes into contact with
sea water i wouldn't suggest pitching
your deck chair there just yet though
britain will begin to share renewable
energy with norway thanks to the launch
of a new subsea power cable connecting
the country's energy grids it means that
hydro power generated in the norwegian
fields could soon be used to keep the
lights on in british homes our science
correspondent thomas small reports
norway is one of the world's biggest
producers of oil and gas but it's water
that provides almost all its domestic
power its steep valleys and abundant
rainfall are perfect for hydro
electricity
huge reservoirs feed a network of pipes
and turbines built inside the mountains
producing so much green energy that some
will now be exported to britain through
a cable under the north sea the longest
in the world
when we talk about this project
people in their minds have you know
visualizing a cable or that size you
know but as you say it's not it's about
this it's um
it's a technology that's been proven and
it works and we can assure you that the
1.4 million households will get
electricity and it will be hydropower
the cable snakes along valleys in the
west of norway before diving beneath the
waves emerging in blythe northumberland
the hydroelectricity it brings should
reduce the uk's carbon emissions by 23
million tons by 2030.
one of the big challenges in the shift
to renewable energy is the intermittency
of supply sometimes the wind doesn't
blow and the sun doesn't shine but hydro
power could help fill the gap in effect
norway can be a giant battery
the uk now generates a quarter of its
electricity from wind but an unusually
calm summer at the same time that the
price of gas the usual standby spiked
left the national grid firing up a coal
power station to keep the lights on
as a result of the of this cable and all
of the other cables bills will fall and
that's because in the uk we can access
cheaper energy from the continent and
transport that energy through our
interconnectors
meaning that the people in the uk are
receiving energy from from cheaper more
plentiful sources of of green
electricity across across continental
europe
green energy could in time be exported
to norway as britain's wind capacity
almost doubles over the next decade but
for now much of the electricity will be
coming the other way once again it's
viking power that crosses the north sea
thomas more sky news in clil dal norway
quick look at what's happening as far as
the weather is concerned for you this
morning rain will clear to sunshine and
blustery showers today with potentially
stormy conditions
over the weekend
now then looking at other news if you
get easily seasick you might not want to
watch these next images
oh look at that this was the scene last
night around 700 miles off the coast of
bermuda with hurricane sam heading
towards the u.s this weekend last night
the storm the storm saw peak wind speeds
of nearly 145 miles an hour forecasters
now say they expect sam to weaken during
the weekend as it heads towards the u.s
still to come on the program for you as
the police face questions for failing to
investigate previous allegations against
sarah everard's murderer we'll speak to
zoe billingham formerly her majesty's
inspector of the constabulary that's
coming up
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello again everybody the amet police
coming under increasing pressure over
their failure to investigate previous
allegations against sarah everard's
murderer wayne cousins as he begins his
whole life tariff earlier i spoke to the
crime and policing minister kit malt
house and asked him just how damaging
this had been for the force
i think as you heard yesterday from
senior police officers they recognized
that this has
struck a a devastating blow to the
confidence that people have in in police
officers out in the public realm um but
also in in the met police in particular
being the met commissioner is i think
one of the
possibly top three most difficult jobs
in the in the country uh you handle
enormous risk you're dealing with an
organization which is capable of amazing
things but at the same time uh things
can go badly wrong as they have done in
this
circumstance and what i want in a in a
policing leader is when
awful calamities like this happen and i
think as crested said yesterday this is
you know probably the worst moment in
the 192 year history of the metropolitan
police um that when these awful things
happen i want a police leader who's
transparent willing to learn willing to
change and is has a conviction and a
commitment uh not to be defensive about
the failings of the organization and i
think that's what we're seeing in
christopher dick
tamara's here but the charge sheet
against her is growing by the month it
would appear that's right a real really
full-throated defense of questa dick by
the policing minister kit malthouse to
some of the claims that she should
resign not just from harriet harman but
also from a conservative mp caroline
notes she chairs the women in equality
committee they say that it's time for a
reset and she's not the person to lead
it but what he said is that
the met needs to be led by someone who
is transparent willing to learn and
willing to change and he says that is
cressida dick now of course she's faced
uh calls to resign several times over
the last few years um over the daniel
morgan murder over the policing of the
sarah everard vigil earlier in the year
and the the the contrast between that
and and the policing of the euros for
example there have been a number of
calls for her to resign but both sadiq
khan and the home secretary pretty patel
who of course jointly appoint her
yesterday um gave broadcast interviews
saying that there were questions for the
police force to answer but it didn't go
as far as calling for her head but there
may be jitters among mps about that
there's certainly a feeling that
something needs to be done and i think
pressure is going to pile on the
government to bring in some kind of
victims law along the lines that that
kierstarma the labour leader was talking
about yesterday to try and urgently
restore trust in the police force while
some of those big errors in vetting go
through independent investigations okay
tomorrow thanks very much indeed let's
bring in uh zoe billingham should we uh
formerly her majesty's inspector of the
constabulary she's just uh described the
actions of wayne cousins who raped and
murdered sarah everard as a hammer blow
to the heart of policing legitimately
with legitimacy with us now thank you
for joining us uh what should happen to
crested addict
morning kay
the met is um
you know an organization that's under
the spotlight and as the policing
minister absolutely said what we need
now is authentic leaders who step
forward and lead and we've seen that in
crested dick we've seen that repeatedly
when the met comes under attack we've
seen that yesterday when she read her
statement outside the old bailey and you
could see and i could see that the sheer
emotion that she managed to contain
uh and the the the gritty determination
that she's showing to get this right and
and i know cressida and i know
very senior officers that she's uh
bought into her most senior management
team some of the most talented women in
policing ac louise rolfe ac helen ball
and for us to be having a debate now
about this you know taking the scalp of
of more women in the context of what
we're talking about is entirely wrong
what we need to be focusing on okay is
what needs to change in policing what
the what policing is as a whole and the
met in particular needs to learn from
this monster and he was a monster
and so that this can never ever happen
again
yeah but her officers her male officers
feel so comfortable that they can
actually share between themselves
homophobic misogynistic comments
um other officers since 2010 hundreds
and hundreds have been investigated only
70 odd have lost their jobs and you know
she is presiding over that doesn't
matter if she's a woman or not she's the
head of the met and this is going on
under her nose
what we found as a former hmi and i led
the report on shining a light on
betrayal
is that we need to stamp out in policing
these misogynistic attitudes this sense
that it's all right to join into banter
which is you know
making fun of women demeaning men women
subverting women away from their kind of
principle activities and we know that
within policing there's been an awful
lot of work done since we published that
report to challenge some of these
attitudes and this is not just about
supporting
male officers and female officers who
speak out against this this is actively
encouraging this to happen and i'm
seeing that happening now in police
forces up and down the land and i know
it's happening to in the met the only
way through this is to address this
issue head-on to not call out the
narrative i i would say that this is a
one-off that this is an aberration wayne
cousins was a monster but we must be
certain that this can never ever happen
again and the debate i think today
should be about looking forward what now
needs to change to make sure that the
trust in policing can be
restored it has been broken
absolutely what now needs to happen in
order to restore trust in our police
so what should happen who should be held
accountable responsible for the misogyny
and murderous behavior of a police
officer that was formerly part of the
met
okay good question we published a report
two weeks ago looking at the way in
which violence against women and girls
is dealt with as a society and within
policing
and we were very clear that this now
needs to be uplifted as an absolute
priority no longer can crimes against
women and girls be treated as second
rate as not important and in order to do
that we've called on the government to
make it clear to police and crime
commission commissioners and chief
constables that this needs to be treated
in the top three priorities of all crime
that the police deal with and until
there's that leadership that says
unequivocally and clearly two police
officers this is important this is your
principal primary role we're going to
struggle to tackle some of those
cultural issues that we're talking about
today okay former met
chief super palm sundew saying yesterday
that female officers don't always report
suspicious behavior of male colleagues
because they close ranks and you risk
being left to get your head kicked in on
duty if you call for help let me just
play this grab to you
if a female officer in particular makes
a a an allegation against a male officer
that allegation will follow her for the
rest of her career if she makes an
allegation and then she has to press the
emergency button for help at a later
date her team may not respond because
teams tend to close ranks there isn't
that sort of um culture where you can
actually bring concerns to the fore and
senior management don't don't always
want to hear those concerns
i did put that to a former a friend of
mine who's a former police officer who
also said that that is something that
she recognized what sort of culture
oversees that
okay i know palm really well she used to
work with me i hear the authenticity
and what she's saying there um i i hear
two
accounts of women in policing not
feeling that they can speak out but i
hear
an overwhelming majority now of police
officers male and female who are
standing together
uh they are not accepting of the
position that they find themselves in
they're standing together to call out
these uh these heinous acts but also
these small
microcosms of behaviors that we know
will lead to escalations of behaviors on
the part of police officers and we now
need to keep create the culture and
environment where people are not only
supportive they're act actively actively
encouraged to step forward and step out
i've worked for 12 years kay in policing
police has been betrayed by this monster
but i am absolutely certain that there
are
hundreds of thousands of police officers
up and down the land who get up every
morning to do nothing but to serve the
public to do the right thing and it's
those police officers that we need to be
focusing on today and encouraging them
to stand together and to call this out
okay thank you for joining us on the
program thank you sorry
me too i mean i have nothing but respect
uh for um our police officers um in in
general they work incredibly hard to
keep us safe day in day out uh night in
night out so um how challenging for them
to get up this morning to continue on
with their work knowing that one of
their own murdered a young girl as she
walked home
on the great debate on monday night
trevor phillips will be asking are women
safe on our streets we want your
experiences your questions for our panel
of experts and your solutions nine
o'clock monday night email the great
debate at sky dot uk to get involved
now today marks the start of black
history months in britain over the
coming weeks campaigners will highlight
ongoing discrimination as well as
celebrating individual achievements sky
news has been speaking to a pioneering
british police officer shimane freeman
powell went to meet michael fuller the
first black police chief constable in
the uk
this is michael fuller
in 2004 he became britain's first and
only black chief constable
but to get there face battles no other
chief constable had to fight
despite the warnings michael persevered
and in 1975
after being brought up in care he left
to join the metropolitan police as a
cadet everybody said there's no way you
do that then my biological parents said
you don't do that
um
my friends and school friends said no
way do you do that even my teachers i
mean everybody i looked up to said don't
join the police that's just not the
thing for a black person to do
in 1981 racial tensions led to violence
in many inner cities
and michael would find himself on a bus
in the middle of a fight between black
and blue
there was this quite sinister atmosphere
outside where there were black hues who
who
came to the side of the bus and started
taunting the police officers on the bus
and the police officers on the bus were
all white and generally a lot older than
me
um but very bitter and twisted i felt
and
used racist exclusives
one of the issues was about belonging
that i didn't belong to the people
uh the the group and the tribe on the
bus and i didn't feel like
i belonged to the tribe outside the bus
i didn't want to make an issue of it
quite the opposite i was not going to
let my color actually hinder me both in
terms of being promoted
and in terms of really
ensuring that i had a fulfilling career
he was successful setting up the racial
and violence crime task force in
response to the death of stephen
lawrence
and as a commander spearheading
operation trident massively reducing gun
violence and black and black crime
in terms of the things i'd like to see
improvements on i'd like to see
increased representation at the senior
levels of the police there haven't been
any other black chief constables
appointed since i was appointed as a
chief constable of a provincial police
force
we need increased representation at
junior levels as well
because there's um
fewer black people actually joining the
police
than there are from other ethnic
minority groups
michael's journey was a long and hard
one but after becoming one of britain's
highest ranking officers he has taken
his place in history
shimane freeman-powell sky news
and black history month will be a
feature of sky news's coverage
throughout october this year's theme
proud to be focuses on celebrating being
black or brown and sharing the pride
that people have in their heritage and
their culture
meantime quick look at the sport for you
here's hannah this morning
ah record breakers me too
world's slowest dog
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by the vitality running world cup
steve on behalf of ryder cup europe the
pg of america our 28 thousand members
across the country i'm really proud to
present you the united states team the
ryder cup
[Applause]
his crowning moment
their crowning moment
12 strong team
individually
just immense together an absolute
juggernaut it's a special day you know
um special day for everybody here
involved you know and it's uh
this ryder cup means a lot to everybody
means a lot to your side it means a lot
to our side and you know to finally
put in a dominant performance here these
guys play great and and
they uh they deserve it they worked hard
at it they were fired up to be here and
uh it showed all a few weeks that we got
involved
seven of the last eight ryder cups have
been won by the home team but is this
more than a home team victory is this a
new era for usa ryder cup golf i sure
feel like it is i mean this uh this
group of guys you know we all talked
about how young this group is and
uh you know they come in with a lot of
um
a lot of fire you know they're they're
friends they get along very well
um and they play great and uh they're
willing to do anything to get to get uh
what they need to do done
any decisions that you look back on and
think yep that was a mistake
now at least that's the one thing i have
i can walk away with that i'm very
comfortable with all the decisions all
along and uh you know
i said that at the start you know
that's something it's a small
consolation but it is a consolation to
me that i'm very happy with all my
decisions along the way what happened
and then you know
just the way it is
what was your highlight moment of the
week there were some good times
we had some very good times in the team
there's no doubt about that and
you know great times in the team room uh
all the week i think on the golf course
it was great to see shane get a point
yesterday afternoon i think tyrell shot
into 18 the first day and
you know those those are strong
highlights obviously john ram and sergio
playing so well that's a you know
particularly that's important as well so
uh you know for future i think that's a
very important one so look there was
there are there was some some highlights
uh just not enough of them in the end of
the day the us played great
um
sorry sorry no take your time take your
time
i know it's tough there's a scoreboard
behind us and these are incredible
[Music]
morning
i'll join later
now on this very day 23 years ago
this happened
sky news sunrise with mark longhurst and
k burley hello very good morning it's
thursday the 1st of october welcome to
the new lock sunrise here at sky news on
the day that we go digital
that was 23 years ago as i said back to
the future not much changes does it
i know i don't i look exactly the same
i know i don't
still to come for you stretched to
breaking point that's what a new study
has said of autism diagnosis in the uk
speaking to the expert on it after the
break
[Music]
[Music]
this will be the
[Music]
i've had a wonderful uh career a very
long time uh
being around and i've done a heck of a
lot of tours around the world
um i was lucky to have three big records
crying vincent and american pie that
were
number ones all over the world and uh
that has fueled my my ability to travel
and
to sing all over the planet and to see
so many things and meet so many
interesting people
and uh gee you know when this pandemic
hit uh i didn't really know what was
gonna happen nobody did and here i am
we're starting to get back uh you know
uh underway and um
i'm very delighted it's an honor really
to be able to do this again i realize
how much i love it and how much i've
missed it
well you know i'm very fortunate that
the few songs that i have
that were very famous are probably
some of the best records i ever made so
you know there are sometimes you get
stuck with a song that's just an
accident and it's kind of lousy and you
have to sing it all the time now that
wasn't the case with me
my best work was the stuff that i was
known for um you know there's always
room for a love song there's always room
for a beautiful song and there's less
and less beauty around
uh as we go through the years as more
and more
loud bombastic
uh
noisy
um
stuff out there that passes for music
but there's less and less
uh of these kinds of songs slower more
more contemplative
and uh more poetic so i i like i like
that
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
[Music]
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body can be damaged by air
pollution
[Music]
the weather's looking unsettled to end
the week and quite stormy over the
weekend for today we've got cloud and
rain clearing away towards the southeast
then skies will brighten but also be
blustery showers rattling in from the
north and the west this is where they'll
be heaviest and most frequent
temperatures 12 to 18 degrees celsius
that says 64 degrees fahrenheit so quite
a bit cooler than it has been recently
in terms of air quality we're looking at
low pollution levels right across the
country not just today but for the
coming few days as well
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
autism diagnosis services are stretched
to breaking point with the number of
people identified with the condition
increasing more than 20 times in the
last two decades uh joined now by uh
ginny russell she's lead author of the
study that made those findings and
senior lecturer at the university of
exeter hello to you thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
why do you think there's been that
increase
well first what i want to emphasize is
that what we're seeing is a rise in
recognition of autism over time so it's
a change in diagnostic practice and not
an increase of the number of people that
have autism per se
and this huge jump is really due to a
combination of factors
partly it's because the criteria for
autism have changed over time
nowadays we know we know that autism is
a spectrum condition and autistic traits
are normally distributed in the
population
and we've also seen in other studies as
time has passed that less severe autism
traits are required in order for a
diagnosis to be assigned so if people
with less severe traits are now
receiving a diagnosis this could partly
explain this sort of exponential and
trended increase in diagnosis because
there are simply more people with less
severe autism traits nearer the
population mean than those with very
severe traits if you sort of mean so
it's a threshold shift in terms of who
goes into that group
who are counted as autistic
um and of course there's increasing what
should parents be looking for in their
child
well
autism symptoms or the criteria for
diagnosing autism um involves social
communication difficulties
and also um restricted and repetitive
behaviors so um that can mean uh
repetitive motor movements like rocking
or hand flapping but those kind of
movements are very normal in very young
children you've all seen kids in the
playground doing this when they get
excited
it's when there's a developmental delay
and these sorts of things
last longer than you'd expect that
autism is commonly diagnosed
okay when someone is diagnosed what are
normally the next steps
well i think one issue our study raises
is that we can't think of autism or
indeed of any medical diagnosis as a
kind of fixed condition
waiting to be identified because the
parameters of who has it changed through
time and some people have said that the
problem with this is that this kind of
catch-all quality makes the diagnosis
clinically less valuable for determining
care
because there's no kind of
one-size-fits-all support that's right
for everyone with autism
so researchers have argued that we need
to be looking instead at subtypes of
people with autism indeed that there are
multiple autism
particularly when designing
interventions and support for children
and for adults
and what sort of challenges does it
create for families when someone uh
within the family is diagnosed with
autism
yeah well i mean the diagnosis itself
can have quite an emotional impact
on
families and there's quite a bit of work
um looking at how people come to
not only accept a diagnosis but also
start to turn that around and think
about autism as something valuable
which provides really positive traits
and we've seen cases of people with
autism like greta thundberg and chris
packham
who are incredible role models
and showing that sort of autistic traits
can have
people with autism can have incredible
strengths
and
so
although it can be a challenging time
for families there's also lots of work
going on by the neurodiversity movement
to destigmatize this diagnosis
and to think about autism in a different
way not just in terms of it being a
problem but also in terms of the the
valuable side of autism and the
strengths that those kind of
neurodevelopmental differences might
bring
fascinating stuff jenny thanks very much
for taking the time to join us thank you
autism uh diagnosis increased 20-fold
we're hearing there from ginny russell
senior lecturer in a critical diagnosis
studies at the university of exeter that
happened just in the last two
decades coming up next for you a
devastating blow to public confidence
we're not saying that the policing
minister kip multis is saying that the
reputation of the police he says has
been damaged after sarah everard was
murdered by a serving police officer but
continues to defend cressida dick's
position as the commissioner of the
metropolitan police we'll be talking
about that in more detail throughout the
morning here on the breakfast show here
on sky news i'm sure that you have a
view the damage caused to the police's
reputation as a result of what happened
with wayne cousins he's starting a whole
life term in prison this morning
back in just a second
[Music]